il est d'un peu plus de 21 heures quand
jean michel fourgous le candidat l'est
républicain vient annoncer sa défaite
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
sa seule satisfaction être en tête dans
sa ville d'elancourt
c'est vrai que mais toujours une petite
déception mais je dirais qu'il ya un tel
tsunami nationale que je suis content de
voir que ma ville n'a pas pris l'eau
entre guillemets pas été touché par
konami bon c'est là où je travaille le
plus quand même
les résultats sont partiels mais il sait
déjà qu'il ne remportera pas ce siège de
député que lui a ravie benoît hamon il
ya cinq ans jean michel fourgous adresse
alors un salut républicain à la gagnante
qu'il va croiser plus tôt que prévu
nadia est rejoint en effet la mairie
d'elancourt après s'être saluer et avoir
transmis quelques conseils
c'est l'occasion aussi pour les deux
adversaires de quelques mises au point
après des échanges tendus pendant la
campagne le déclaratif c'est bien le
mieux c'est
donc il faut bien que les gens attendent
d'un soldat rapide
un défi une gagnante nouvelle en
politique qui après une campagne de
terrain a relayé le message du président
de la république voit ses efforts
récompensés
elle est élue avec 52,96 % des voix
contre 47 0 4%
pour jean michel fourgous un 2e tour
marqué par un record d'abstention 58,3 %
en forte augmentation par rapport au
premier tour
je suis effectivement extrêmement
satisfaite des du résultat après après
-selon semaine de travail
ces longues semaines où je suis allé à
la rencontre de nous de nos concitoyens
et c'est aussi une grande fierté
aujourd'hui pour moi d'en arriver là
effectivement il ya quelques mois
j'étais cadre dans une banque
aujourd'hui je suis député à l'assemblée
nationale auprès du président emmanuel
macron donc pour moi c'est d'autant plus
une immense fierté de porter un projet
un projet comme celui là qui est de
solides celui de la république en marche
à seulement 30 77 femmes actives cadre à
paris est originaire de trappes devient
la 11e députés en marche des yvelines
ces priorités d'élus la moralisation de
la vie politique et la réforme du code
de travail qui emmanuel macron compte
mettre en oeuvre dès cet été
elle va mettre en place une permanence
dans sa circonscription et a lancé une
plateforme collaborative pour donner la
parole aux habitants de la 11e
circonscription
[Applaudissements]
après une soirée où elle retrouve sa
famille ses amis ses soutiens et les
marcheurs
elle salue tous ceux qui l'ont
accompagné durant cette campagne
vous avez quitté votre temps
personnellement professionnelles et
familiales parfois effectivement ça vous
compliqué je sais
mais vous l'avez paix et je vous
remercierai jamais assez pour ce que
vous avez fait et oui nous l'avons fait
nous avons battu venoix avant nous avons
21 ans michel fargo elle sait qu'elle va
devoir s'installer vite pour travailler
dans ces bureaux de l'assemblée
elle y partira d'ailleurs pour une
visite dès demain matin avant une
session de formation pour les nouveaux
arrivants et la journée d'ouverture de
la prochaine législature avec l'ensemble
des députés prévu le 27 juin